good afternoon my name is Jim Neal I'm
the librarian here at Columbia and i'd
like to welcome you to this inaugural
event in our scholarly communication
program speaker series we have entitled
the series research without borders the
changing world of scholarly
communication there will be six events
over the course of the academic d ear
and outside we have information about
our two other events this fall our goals
are to raise the level of understanding
and the level of conversation at
columbia about the important changes in
scala communication and to inspire
action on policy and practice I thank
the staff of our center for digital
research and scholarship and Catherine
Pope who was very much the conceiver and
the executor she made this happen and I
appreciate all of her all of her all of
her efforts so let's think for a second
what do we mean by scala communication
do we mean the creation the transmission
the evaluation and the preservation of
new knowledge what is this urge to
publish why do our faculty our
researchers produce so much stuff well
this is the way they communicate this is
part of the academic culture in which
they've been raised it's the way their
ideas get preserved it's a way in many
ways how they achieve their prestige and
recognition as individual members of the
academic community but what is this
thing we've come to call the crisis in
scholarly publishing well the library
community for the last three decades or
so has been like a Greek chorus standing
on the side of the stage screaming at
the academic community it costs too much
it takes too long to get from author to
reader we give too much away and you in
the academic community you don't care
about this problem well we've learned
that over the past decade what was the
serials crisis the library's crisis has
been embraced for the large
international
public policy question that it really is
and we've learned that there are some
things that we in the faculty have been
collectively advocating we clearly want
a competitive and not dysfunctional
marketplace but maybe that is too
conforming and to Darwinian or
capitalistic maybe we need to think
about more transformative approaches to
scholarly publishing we want the easy
distribution and reuse of publications
we want innovative applications of
technology we don't want to give up
quality and we want to make sure that
whatever is produced is permanently
archived for future use but the Academy
the researcher community has in fact
forged ahead and system transforming
models and sort of take back the means
of production tactics are really at work
and being advanced and exploited today
we welcome Stuart cheaper to talk about
the Harvard open access initiatives he
is the Welsh professor of computer
science in the School of Engineering and
Applied Sciences at Harvard his research
area is computational linguistics the
study of human languages from the
perspective of computer science he
received as a bee from Harvard in 81 his
PhD in computer science from Stanford in
89 he was given a presidential young
investigator award in 91 and was named a
presidential faculty fellow in 93 one of
only 30 in the country in all the areas
of Science and Engineering at Harvard he
has been awarded two honorary chairs the
John elbow of associate professorship at
Natural Sciences that was in 93 and the
Harvard College professorship in 2001 he
was named a fellow of the American
Association for artificial intelligence
in 2004 and he was the founding director
of the Center for Research on
computation in society and he has been
faculty co-director at the Berkman
Center for Internet and Society is
currently as I said on the faculty but
most importantly for our our talk today
he's the director
the new office for scholarly
communication so he's a researcher he's
an author he's a teacher he's an
evaluator and he's a consumer of
scholarly work we can now add his resume
leader and perhaps provocateur professor
schieber will present and then he will
entertain your questions and comments
and that will be followed by a brief
recession reception professor Sheba
welcome well thank you very much for
that kind introduction and thank you for
the opportunity to talk to you today
about some efforts that have been going
on at Harvard for the last few years
intended to broaden access to the
Faculty's collective scholarly output
what I thought I'd do is I'll give some
background on these Harvard efforts in
particular describing the new open
access policy at Harvard in a couple of
the schools at Harvard and I'll mention
some of the the background for the
policy how the policy works some of the
external views of our activities and I
also wanted to talk today about another
initiative that's unlike the open access
policy that has actually been instituted
is just still just a gleam in my eye but
I I'm hoping to get some of your
feedback on this other idea that I'll
float today but first let me talk about
the Harvard open access policy and give
some background on that I've duplicated
here on this slide a couple of sentences
from a document and the Faculty of Arts
and Sciences at Harvard called the gray
book which is the statement of research
policies that faculty like myself serve
under and I do that to highlight the
notion that it's a an essential
part of research policy that research at
the university should be used for the
greatest possible public benefit and as
a consequence of that should receive the
widest possible dissemination this is a
basic idea behind the mission of the
University of course keeping in mind
that it's the right of a scholar to
decide to publish a book or an article
and if so when and under what
circumstances still this should be done
for the greatest public benefit with the
widest possible dissemination and now
the question is what is the method what
what are the methods we should use to
achieve this goal well of course in the
past the methods we've used have
involved publication of the two greats
and publication of the ideas in journals
and Conference proceedings and similar
venues and that would be an ideal way to
do this if economics was not getting in
the way so i'll start by talking about
this this problem the so-called serials
crisis this crisis in scala
communication that Jim Neal referred to
its with some trepidation that I start
with the discussion of the costs of this
scholarly communication mechanism we
find ourselves in because the real issue
i want to emphasize again is not the
cost of cereals but the reduction in
access that that is the problem because
remember it's the the idea is that we
want the widest possible access for our
writings so reduction in access works
against that goal but I'll do it anyway
I'll start to talk about some economics
anyway on this slide I show the Consumer
Price Index that's the lower blue line
and then the cereal expenditures as a
function of time so you can see that
cereal expenditures these are for all
the ARL libraries from statistics from
by 2006 serial expenditures have in ARL
libraries have been going up at
something like four times the rate of
inflation pretty steadily for several
decades now now what's the effect of
this you know how exponential growth
works this kind of growth and costs is
just unsustainable you can't continue
subscribing to journals with that kind
of inflation over time it's going to
have an effect on something and the
effect its had at least at Harvard is
reducing collections of monographs
canceling serials almost complete
elimination of duplicate subscriptions
and a reduction in access because of all
those cancellations and reductions in
collections now Harvard is fortunate in
having the world's largest academic
library the fifth largest library in the
world over 15 million volumes and what
is a relatively munificent endowment you
might think that Harvard would be immune
to this problem does hyperinflation in
serials market but you actually look at
Harvard's serial expenditures you see
that it's not the case this middle line
here in purple is Harvard serial
expenditures over that same period of
time and you notice we did a pretty good
job trying to keep up with the inflation
in serials for many years until about Oh
2004 and then you see this a decrease in
slope the technical name for that is
giving up
at a certain point you know budgets
cannot hyper inflate as much as we might
like the library budgets too hyper and
plate now I'll see the Harvard library
budget did hyper inflate until right
about that time actually a year or two
before the budget the Harvey diversity
library was growing at a little bit
above the rate of inflation of the
Harvard budget overall for many years
and it was because of this
hyperinflation in the costs and a few
years ago people realized that that's
just not sustainable if you keep doing
that long enough then all eventually all
of the budget of Harvard will be going
to the library and all those other
things that Harvard does but not as
important as the functions of the
library will not be able to be done at
all things like Oh teaching and research
so so eventually it was understood that
this couldn't this couldn't be sustained
now underlying the underlying cause of
this hyperinflation it's important to
realize is a market failure not not
increasing real costs and let me say why
I why I say that how you can see that if
you look at the cost I mean and I mean
kind of subscription cost subscription
charge per page for journals in
different fields and this the data on
this slider to taken from a study by
Bergstrom in Bergstrom the graph shows
price per page in six different fields /
whether the publisher is a commercial
publisher or nonprofit publisher like a
scholarly society and you see that the
cost per page is six times higher for
commercial journals
so this is an extraordinary difference
in the cost of journals between the
commercial publishers and the non-profit
publishers now you might think well
maybe that's because the commercial
journals are higher quality journals and
that quality means that they have higher
costs because that would be more
selective and they have to add more
value and so forth and and therefore
that's why their cost per page is so
much higher well we can look at that too
we can take a look at not cost per page
but a cost per citation using citation
as a proxy for quality it's not a great
proxy but it's better than nothing a lot
to correlate someone we can look at the
cost per citation for these different
journals and here turns out that the
differential is even larger the cost per
citation is 16 times higher for
commercial journals and for nonprofit
journals so what this tells you is first
of all it's not that the commercial
journals are much better and therefore
they're more expensive arguably in terms
of quality at least as measured by
citation they're not as good and yet
they're 16 times higher how can an
industry have be selling goods different
companies selling goods that are
essentially the same kind of goods I
mean journals published by commercial
journals and nonprofit journals are
quite similar in in all ways except that
they happen to have different content to
them and yet have this huge differential
in price that's a sign of a systemic
market failure somewhere along the line
so something needs to get done to solve
that problem in the long run if we're
going to rely on subscriptions as our
means of access because without dealing
with that problem subscriptions will
continue to hyper inflate and that will
lead to this continued reduction in
access so either we need to solve this
problem or we need
find some other way of achieving access
to these articles well it was issues
like this that got people thinking in at
Harvard of course elsewhere too about
what the university can do to mitigate
these access problems in the short run
probably can't solve these fundamental
systemic market failures but at least
maybe we can find some way around to
directly affect the access problem so
because of that in October of 2005 the
Provost at Harvard organized a committee
that I chaired to take a look at these
scholarly communications issues and we
focused initially exactly on the this
kind of topic that sometimes called the
serials crisis and in a few months later
made some short report to the Provost
making some recommendations here I've
just listed three of the main
recommendations there were other issues
that were discussed in the report but
just to mention the three main
recommendations that were in the report
the first was to establish an office for
scholarly communication which was set up
just now just a few months ago the
second was that faculties might
Institute open access policies to
directly address this issue of
reconstructing access to the writings of
Harvard faculty and third that the
university might support open access
journal charges and I'll come back to
that towards the end of the talk so
mostly I want to talk for the next
little while about this second
recommendation that faculties might
Institute open access policies and we
have since done that in two of the about
ten faculties of of the university we've
instituted up an open access policy in
the Faculty of Arts
sciences and in the now in the law
school and the Harvard policy has three
main parts i'll just go over and have we
just get a sense how many people have
heard of this Harvard open access policy
so you may be familiar with with some of
this but just review there's three
important aspects to the policy the
first is that faculty members grant
permission to the University to
distribute their scholarly articles the
second is that in order to make sure
that the policy cannot stand in the way
of the best interests of the authors a
waiver of the policy will be issued for
any article at the sole discretion of
the author so there's this process of
requesting a waiver it's described as a
waiver request for technical reasons
it's the the licensee that has to waive
the author can't waive it but so there
has to be a request for a waiver but the
waiver will be granted upon request
there's no discretion on anyone's part
except for the author and then the third
part is a deposit requirement so the
university can take advantage of this
permission that it has and that the
policy enables the faculty make their
articles available by depositing a copy
in the Harvard repository so together
these parts there's a the permission the
waiver and the deposit make up the
policy that constitutes the action of
the faculty Arts and Sciences and now
the Harvard Law School okay now looking
again at this first part of the policy
I'll just mention that faculty members
grant to university permission to make
articles available this provides an
alternate supplementary means of access
to the articles and that course is the
entire point of the policy since we
can't rely on the
cereals publishing system increasingly
can't rely on it this is a way of of
augmenting that system with an
alternative means of access for the
articles so there's this non-exclusive
license now there is a little problem
that this not permission that the
university has may be inconsistent with
the standard copyright assignment that a
publisher may want an author to sign so
here I've given a section from
Blackwell's copyright assignment they
call it their exclusive license form and
it says that in order for your article
be distributed as widely as possible
this is their idea as widely as possible
in the journal you grant the publisher
an exclusive license to publish the
above article now there's a problem here
because you've granted permission to
Harvard to as a faculty member all
faculty members now as of februari 12
last year this past year have granted a
non-exclusive license to Harvard to
distribute the article so how can I sign
an exclusive license to Blackwell if the
article has this non-exclusive license
to Harvard well I can't those are
inconsistent and a faculty member needs
to make them consistent somehow or other
and there's two ways to do that the
first thing we've done is we've provided
a system for generating an addendum to
copyright assignments so this is a
little form on the web that you fill in
the title of the article and the journal
and so and so forth and press a button
at the bottom says generate addendum and
it pops up this addendum with all the
information filled out that you can then
print out sign and attached to the
copyright assignment and what this
addendum says essentially is it carves
out exactly the non-exclusive license
that Harvard has so it says
notwithstanding the copyright agreement
the article is subject to this
an exclusive license to to Harvard to
distribute it so that's one way to make
the Harvard policy consistent with the
publication agreement and the other way
of course is to request a waiver of the
policy that's fine too either way either
you amend the cop in a tent or you
request a waiver of the policy of course
if you request a waiver the policy the
policy doesn't hold then there's nothing
to be made consistent you can do
anything you want with the copyright
assignment and of course we hope that
people will not request waivers unless
they really need to or there's some
commanding reason to but it's up to the
up to the faculty member okay so that's
one thing that the faculty need to do to
comply with this policy they need to
either generate an addendum and catch it
or or request a waiver and the other
thing of course is to deposit into a
repository and we're just now I'm
embarrassed to say is finally setting up
a repository university-wide repository
that will serve as the infrastructure
for distributing these articles and it
will take the deposits repository is
called dash which stands for digital
access to scholarship at Harvard and
this is kind of the front page as it
currently looks we're still in it says
in big type at the top we're in beta
here so the dash repository is not
available openly on the web yet as we're
still working out the kinks and getting
things going but we're getting it under
way and hope in the near term that that
will be available and faculty are
starting to put articles into the
repository so that's the Harvard open
access policy and the policy has a
number of nice effects remembering that
the point of the policy is to try to
make it possible to get broader access
to Harvard authors writings in the face
of
these problems in subscription-based
journals so number of advantages of the
policy first it makes a collective
statement of principle that we think
it's important that there be the
broadest possible access to our writings
and I put by the way these these
advantages I take them to be in order of
importance so from the most to the least
important second it provides for
acquiring in a systematic manner
metadata about the articles that the
faculty publishes why is that it's
because for every article and a faculty
member either needs to generate an
addendum or request a waiver and in
either case we find out about the
existence of the article and that it's
an article that's important to maximize
the access of and we can take steps to
do that even if so if it falls under the
open access policy and an addendum has
been generated of course we can Harvard
has a license to distribute it if waiver
is requested well at least we still know
about the existence of the article and
we may still be able to distribute the
article because many copyright
arrangements with publishers these days
allow distribution through repositories
even without these kinds of addenda
third is that it completely clarifies
the right situation for the articles so
for every article we know either it
falls under the policy and then
definitively the university has a right
to distribute it or a waiver has been
requested and we know the information
about the article the journal and the
publisher and so forth that allows us to
clarify the right situation with respect
to that journal and publisher and so
we'll know the right situation in either
case forth it allows the university to
facilitate the article deposit process
because the university actually has a
license and fifth it moves some
negotiating ability from
an individual to the university as a
whole so it's the university now that
has all of these rights and to the
extent that there's some middle ground
between the university's view of what
would be the optimal set of Rights and a
publisher's view what what would be the
optimal set of Rights the university as
a single entity can negotiate on behalf
of the of the faculty on those kinds of
issues compare that to the current
situation where each for each article an
author needs to individually negotiate
with with a publisher about rights if
that author is willing to do so and
finally sixth would maybe the least
important although it gets most of the
attention is that the policy changes the
rights retention situation from an
opt-out situation sorry from an opt-in
situation to an opt-out situation and
that may increase the amount of Rights
retained we don't know probably not
gonna make any worse and it may actually
increase the amount of Rights retention
if if experience is any predictor in
other areas where we go from opt in to
opt-out those kinds of moves tend
increase and increase some compliance
and participation in these kinds of
arrangements but we don't know so it has
a bunch of nice advantages I thought I'd
say a few words about the process that
we undertook in in engaging the Faculty
of Arts and Sciences in law school in
discussing the policy and in getting
them to approve the policy as I said
before there was a report
submitted to the provost right around
the same time was the first meeting with
faculty of sfas in this particular case
that was the library committee that
oversees the Harvard College Library to
talk about this policy patha possibility
this policy that was in February of 2006
and the policy itself was voted in
February of 2008 and between the two
here I've listed the some of the major
meetings that occurred on campus to
discuss the policy I haven't any means
listed all of them so you can see there
was a lot of discussion on campus we met
with so-called caucus of chairs as the
chairs of all the departments in FAS the
faculty of council we met with four
times which as far as I can tell is
unprecedented never heard of any other
topic coming before the faculty Council
more than twice but this one for some
reason took four meetings met with the
subcommittee of the Board of Overseers
of the University of various individual
departments that's not even on here
there were two meetings of the full
faculty a couple of open forums on the
motion for faculty and for librarians
that with the Council of Dean's and FAS
and so forth so a lot of discussion very
open process on campus to talk about the
policy and to make sure that people
understood what it was and wasn't what
the goals were have people's worries
about the policy aired and made sure
that everyone had a chance to to
object where they thought there were
valid objections similar process and
about a similar amount of time took
place at the law school again about two
years from the very first time it was
discussed with Harvard Law School
faculty to May of 2008 when the law
school faculty voted to approve the
policy so so that's the open access
policy it's very new we don't know to
what extent will have compliance with
the policy that what extent will be able
to populate the repository it's a little
L we're just still in the in the
beginnings of of implementing it that
hasn't stopped people from talking about
it outside of the University I've taken
a selection of some of the external
views of this policy on the next few
slides here's for instance what our
local newspaper the Boston Globe said
about the policy they called it a bold
move to boost the unrestricted global
use of research articles this is not
just a local news story apparently it
was an international news story as well
here's the Italian paper of record
Corriere della Sera predicting that the
Harvard decision will accelerate the
ongoing process of reorganizing the
means by which knowledge is disseminated
now since I'm the one giving the talk I
get to pick the quotes so I show you
these quotes but just in in the interest
of honesty there were other quotes that
maybe should be looked at not everyone
was so impressed with the Harvard policy
here is the Association of American
publishers who say that's just a gambit
in a price dispute that libraries are
just upset that their budgets are far
less than desirable by were desirable I
take it he means what the public
would desire that the budgets are so the
AAP thinks we just need to face reality
and raise the library budgets and keep
paying larger amounts for less and less
access which is a pretty good way to do
things if you're a publisher here's
another reaction from the inside higher
ed says Harvard self-serving move
weakened standards of peer review
process so this is a and it's I have to
say this is a relatively representative
reaction to the Harvard policy it's
based of course on a misunderstanding of
the role of repositories and archiving
the idea here is not to have anything to
do at all with peer review processes
there is no peer review in the
repository so it doesn't weaken the peer
review process it's not an alternative
to a peer review process it's a
supplement to the peer review process
peer review process stays exactly as it
was before the entire journal publishing
mechanism works exactly as it does does
before with peer review at the same
level of standards it's just that in
addition to that we now have an
alternative means of getting access to
articles written by Harvard authors and
then I especially like the second part
of this quote where he says that that
the policy presumes that any garbage
Harvard profs right would have been
worthy of publication which is true
ah but as it turns out is also
irrelevant because the policy has
nothing to do with the peer review
process which is designed to disabuse
Harvard faculty of this idea that any
garbage that we write is worthy of
publication so it helps to have a thick
skin to a certain extent when you look
at the reactions to the policy these
particular reactions I think are
misguided but there were some legitimate
objections at least on their face
legitimate objections the Harvard policy
and I thought I'd talk about those a bit
talk about some of the standard
objections that got talked about on
campus in great detail over this
two-year period a lot of discussions on
on these kinds of issues and I'm not
going to go over them all in great
detail but i'll mention some of them and
then talk about some in more detail so
the first is a question whether this
violates faculty rights somehow somehow
somehow impinges on academic freedom
that that you're telling the faculty
where they have to publish or how they
have to publish the I have to say
they're not a lot of you didn't get a
lot of this reaction but a few people
would air this issue to a great extent
that the any possibility that there
would be some kind of violation of
faculty rights is completely mitigated
by the fact that there's a waiver that's
purely at the discretion of the faculty
member so if you think that there's some
problem with the policy working on a
particular article or all of your
articles you can get a waiver of the
policy for an article or for all of your
articles
so in that sense the in the in the words
of Cass Sunstein that this kind of
policy is a policy of libertarian
paternalism yes it's maybe paternalistic
but it does so in a libertarian way now
maybe some people think that even
libertarian paternalism is still too
paternalistic but the question is
whether there's any choice in the matter
I mean whatever policy you have there's
going to be an effect on where the
rights in one's writings land without
this kind of policy we find ourselves in
a system of essentially required
publishing we're required to publish as
part of what we do for our career that
has faculty hand over copyright to
publishers wholesale which means that
the scholars aren't free to use their
scholarship as they see fit for that
reason so it's not like we have a choice
in the matter over what restrictions
there will be to the rights in fact this
is a the fact that we retain some rights
actually may be taken to be to show that
the existing system is a greater
violation of academic freedom than one
under this policy so I said more about
that this first objection than I I
should have I mean to go into that much
detail the next three policies the three
objections are kind of related there are
worries that this might put scholarly
societies out of business or kill peer
review that somehow we're stealing the
valuable work of the publishers by
giving away articles for free or that
open access has no business model and
that I'm economically that you're
economically naive by proposing it and
I took this fourth objection very much
to heart because when they said you're
economically naive the you they're
referring to was me so I kind of take
that personally I don't like to think of
myself as economically naive all of
these three objections two through four
are based on us on a single scenario
which I'll go through on the next slide
and I want to spend most of my time
talking about this objection because I
think it's a really worth worth while
talking about it and it's important and
it's it's not a misguided worry it's an
important issue to fully understand and
address and then there was a fifth
objection which is that we didn't go far
enough we should have gone much farther
we should have dropped the waiver
process that it should have been a
mandate not just move from an opt-in to
an opt-out situation but an actual
mandate at least for the deposit part
now this objection is especially useful
because it's always good to have people
objecting on both sides of you because
then you look completely reasonable if
it weren't for this objection people
would think that I'm a nut for proposing
this kind of policy but now you can see
I could have gone even farther so maybe
I'm not so crazy after all okay that's
all I'll say about that most people want
to ask about about that issue but I want
to concentrate on these those middle
objections that had to do with this kind
of dystopian scenario that people worry
about so here's the here's this those of
that those kinds of objections that this
will this will harm peer review it will
put journals out of business scholarly
societies will suffer and so forth these
are all based on a certain extrapolation
of this policy not the policy itself so
the first issue is we have to imagine
that at some time in the more or less
distant future many years from now
all universities will have followed suit
following Harvard Harvard likes to
imagine that we control in some manner
through moral suasion or something how
other universities act but you of course
no it's not true we tried for instance
to to get rid of early action for
undergraduate admissions need a big
announcement we work into early action
I've been a lot of discussion of early
action before then how early action was
problematic and and all the universities
should get rid of it and if just someone
would go first then we'd all follow and
so Harvard said okay we'll go first and
we got rid of early action nothing of it
so the notion that we can do something
and then everybody just follow suit
incredibly naive but let's imagine that
it would happen that all the
universities would follow suit and that
all all these policies are enacted and
very successful and huge percentage of
the articles are available open access
through this alternative venue so that
in addition to being available from
publishers they're also available in
these repositories well you could
imagine you could get so much access to
articles in a particular journal such a
high percentage of the articles in the
journal would be available and the value
added between the publishers version of
the article and the author's vers might
be small enough that a library would
start feeling freer to cancel a
subscription to that journal and maybe
many libraries would start feeling free
or to cancel subscriptions so they don't
need the subscriptions anymore to get
access of a sufficiently good quality
for their patrons and what would what
would that do that would cause price
pressure on journal subscription fees
and if you're willing more willing to
cancel then the publishers can't command
as high prices now the the first two
steps here are of course the open access
goal of repositories that's
the whole point we want to get wider
access at least two in case of the
Harvard policy to Harvard authors but
the more the better that's the goal of
repositories and deposit policies three
through four here on this list this is
the potential financial benefit to
libraries of this kind of policy
although there's an empirical question
as to whether this would occur at all to
the extent we have any empirical
evidence it's to the contrary so in the
one case we have of a field that has
essentially wholesale open access to
authors version of articles that's
physics we haven't seen a cancellation
of library subscriptions and the
journals are are still maintaining the
subscriptions and the publishers are
still publishing the journals
nonetheless not all fields are physics
maybe maybe this would play out in the
way envisioned here and you'd have some
price pressure on journal subscription
fees well from that that second slide I
showed with the differential in prices
between the commercial and
non-commercial journals a little price
pressure on publishers may not be a bad
thing you can see that there's
apparently a lot of room to maneuver in
the prices for commercial journals so
that wouldn't be a bad thing of course
the price pressure would start exactly
on the most expensive and
least-efficient journals which is
exactly where you'd want it to be
nonetheless continuing this dystopian
scenario what would happen if the price
pressure was so grave that journals
couldn't even recoup their costs I can
remember we're extrapolating how many
years in the future when all the
universities have have kind of gotten on
board with open access and all the
faculty and authors are doing this kind
of thing and maybe the journals wouldn't
be able to recoup their costs anymore so
what would a publisher do in that case
well you
operated a loss so you either have to
change business model or you have to
close the journal and that's exactly the
worry that that this scenario is
envisioning that the publishers wouldn't
be able to change the business model of
the journal and the journal and
therefore the scholarly society that
runs it or the peer review process that
it enables and so and so forth all these
very good things admittedly important
aspects of the scholarly communication
system that we have would disappear and
this would be a truly terrible future if
it were to come about now there's a lot
of gifts between now and this scenario a
lot of things that might go quite
differently in particular there's this
number six here six is really the
critical issue the idea is that the
publishers will not be able to change
the business model for the Germans now
there is an alternate business model
that people have proposed for journals a
different business model from charging
for access subscription fees that are
charged to gain access you have
subscription fees to charge for access
the only way you can make a business out
of that is if you limit the access in
the first place to those people who are
willing to pay the subscription fees so
if you can't do that in this scenario
can't limit access anymore isn't so you
can't charge for it so you have to find
a business model what will that be well
the alternative business model primary
alternative dispel people talked about
is so-called open access journals this
is I'm Tomic different thing now from
the open access from the first part of
the top or time putting things
supplementally in a repository now I'm
talking about a journal publishing model
where the journal articles themselves
from the publisher available open access
and the publisher recoups expenses by
some other means typically through
article processing fees
so you don't limit access you just
charge up front for the services that
the journal provides namely the managing
of the peer review the logistics the
copy editing the typesetting reworking
figures you know all that managing the
websites and so on and so forth all of
the things that are involved in running
a journal that's distributed freely from
there on and all those costs our first
copy was sometimes called first copy
cost so it makes sense to charge them
only once per article as a fee per
article an article processing fee so
that seems like a reasonable business
model the problem is that as a publisher
you may not be able to change to that
business model imagine you're a
publisher publishing let's take my own
field of computer science you publish a
journal a computer science journal and
you find again in this extrapolated
world that all of the papers in computer
science are available open access
libraries are canceling subscriptions
left and right because you're not
providing any service to them access
service and you're entertaining the
notion of changing the business model
you're going to stop charging
subscription fees and you're going to
start charging an article processing fee
well you can't you're you you'd be the
only computer science journal to charge
article processing fees it's just not
done in computer science so what said
what's an author going to do when they
see I like and publish in in your
journal and it's going to cost me a
thousand dollars for an article
processing fee or I can publish in any
of the other computer science journals
where it costs me nothing they're gonna
they're going to vote with their feet
and go to the other journals or at least
and there'll be some movement and
you run the risk of lowering the quality
of the journal which of course is that's
the journals bread and butter and it
might even be considered a fiduciary
responsibility to change the business
if you're a commercial firm that's
illegal you have to serve the best
inches of your shareholders you can't do
it so the publishers are in a bind and I
have to say I feel for the publishers I
I mean it's it's this is it's a real
issue so what can we do about that
problem now and so now I want to turn to
this other proposal that I'm floating
but I don't wanna do that till I
emphasize once again that this entire
discussion is extraordinarily
speculative that is there may have been
no problem here even in the first place
because it was based on all this
extrapolation and trying to bring
futures way out in the distance and so
forth trying to predict how markets work
and I know about you but I'm not feeling
very good these days about predicting
how markets work so on what we need to
do is find some way that reduces the
risk to a publisher of changing their
business model publishers provide
extremely valuable services to faculty
authors to universities to funding
agencies that are funding the research
that the publishers are helping to vet
and improve and distribute those are
valuable services and they deserve to be
paid for they're not cost-free and we
need to pay for them and now the
question is who's going to pay for them
well I think we need to put our money
where our mouth is and the people who
should pay for them are the universities
and the funding agencies first of all
that's who's paying for them now right
now those services are hidden inside the
subscription fees they're recouped
through subscription fees and who pays
that the universities through library
budgets and the funding agencies through
overheads to the universities that go to
the library budgets that pay the
subscription fees so we know in
aggregate the funding
agencies and universities are already
paying enough money have enough money to
pay for the services in aggregate that
the publishers are providing these very
important valuable services the issue is
not is there enough money it's how do we
channel the money we channel it through
this dysfunctional market based on
subscription fees or do we channel it
through a functional market but we need
to channel it one way or another and I
and if we entertain channeling it
through open access article processing
fees then we need to step up the plate
and say that's what we'll do that
universities will commit to underwriting
and here I come to what I called the
Harvard compact a Harvard compact is is
signing on to the following statement
that university commits to underwrite
reasonable article processing fees for
open access journals for which funds are
not otherwise available there are a lot
of details here and I can talk about
them but the basic idea is this that the
University will pay open access article
processing fees that's the basic idea an
author wants to publish in an open
access journal that charges thousand
dollars to for the article processing
fees and doesn't have a grant to fund
this thousand dollars the University
will pay it so now the author is in a
different position the author doesn't
need to decide should I publish in this
open access journal or commercial
journal that's charging no article
processing fees but subscription fees
instead well in now the choice isn't is
it a thousand dollars out of my pocket
because the university is going to pay
for that so is zero dollars out of the
art authors pocket in either case and
now the open access journals and the
closed access journals are on a bit more
equal footing not completely equal still
but a bit more equal footing more
importantly if we extrapolate in the
same way we extrapolated
to get to this dystopian scenario if we
simultaneously extrapolate the Harvard
compact you notice the risk to the
publisher of changing models from a
subscription fee based model to an
article fee based model disappears the
the journal doesn't have to wonder
whether authors will move to some other
journal because they're going to be out
the article processing fees did journal
the publisher will know that the
universities collectively have committed
to paying article processing fees so the
risk is mitigated there are lot of
details here that are the subject of
ongoing discussions at Harvard and that
we can talk about what articles would be
eligible what's the fee structure what
venues of publication would be eligible
to be to receive these fees and and caps
of various sorts and how the puff policy
would be reviewed and so forth but maybe
I will not go into great detail here and
kind of leave that to these questions to
arise during during the question period
a couple of objections people might
think of which we can also talk about I
won't go into now one objection might be
well maybe Harvard could afford the
Harvard compact of underwriting these
open access publication fees but not too
many other universities could afford it
it'll be it'll be just hugely expensive
so that's a worry that we might have we
can talk about that there is it kind of
a converse worry is well this only works
if there's universal acceptance of the
of the compact very different from the
open access policy open access policy
works in Harvard faculties interest even
if our word is the only University that
has such a policy but here the whole
basis for the idea is that it would be
taken up wholesale so
we can talk about those two let me just
summarize maybe with the main points
were here in this in this talk and then
we'll open up to questions first thing I
want to emphasize is that this is a
university faculty problem that this
this problem of dysfunction in the
scholarly communication system and it
requires University and faculty action
to resolve it it's not as it sometimes
has been described a library problem
that requires library action the second
is there are two parts to the problem
there's an access problem and for that
we hope that this Harvard open access
policy will mitigate the access problem
but there's also a separate business
model problem that the that the Harvard
open access policy has nothing to do
with and the hope there is that that can
be at least partially mitigated by the
Harvard compact so let me stop there and
I'll take questions on any or all of
these topics yeah I know are you think
about this news you mentioned articles
of the outset is this doesn't apply
folks that are respectable the
publishing industry we decided
they go to show the academic publishing
industry of books has its own set a
problem if there is indeed yeah the
question whether whether this Harvard
open access probably pies to books the
book publishing industry academic book
publishing she has its own problems I
think their problems of a different sort
from the journal publishing system and
therefore requires different solutions
the Harvard open access policy does not
apply to books it applies only to what
we refer to as scholarly articles so
these are and you can think of what the
core cases of scholarly articles are
articles in scholarly journals refereed
conference proceedings that that kind of
thing not popular articles not books
monographs not educational materials
pedagogical materials so it's it's it's
focused on exactly this area of
scholarly articles where we're seeing
this particular kind of market
dysfunction that's leading to reduction
in access but the question of book
publishing is also an interesting area
and it's not something that we have
concrete proposals on yet although
there's a lot of interest to try to
figure out what can be done so very hard
problem and again it also has this
property that the library sees the
problem but the library is more or less
a recipient of the problem that is it's
a faculty problem to a great degree
especially in the humanities where what
has driven the problem is the implicit
collective requirement of faculty and
Humanities to see a book publishing as a
means of career advancement yeah neutran
and editorial recently
slightly different business models of
public library science and environment
central in the biomedical domain and
they were maintaining that gloss which
does it make six journals of C or
primary journals and what they call the
nature cash count plus one and then the
firemen central has many doesn't
remember journals I've had experience
with both and very interesting but they
they maintain the biomed central is able
to do better because they had such a
multitude of journals and a different
peer review process that's completely
transparent that we have like make cash
cows however i heard recently that I
think biomed Central's up for sale no
it's been sold yeah what nature was I
haven't read that editorial but i'll
i'll tell you what i think about place
to the publishers um I'm not and I'm not
a big expert on the finances of plus and
biomed central but the first thing to
note is that you you probably not a good
idea to extrapolate from the experience
of plus plus is an outlier as a
publisher in many ways in the same way
that nature publishing group that which
publishes nature triple-a ass which
publishes science there's a small set of
journals that work very differently from
the vast bulk of the tens of thousands
of journals that are published every
year and plus is in that same group with
science and nature and New England
Journal of Medicine where first of all
not all of the content a lot of the
content
those journals isn't academic
contributed peer-reviewed content so
they have writing staffs that right a
lot of the material and of course that's
very expensive so they have a whole
different range of overheads that your
average journal doesn't have and
consequently their expenses are much
higher and that's why you see their
article processing fees are much higher
than biomed central as well and even at
the whatever it is now 28 50 or so that
plus is charging for article the
argument is that they're not breaking
even on those articles and so plus one
kind of under rights these other
articles so I have great respect for
public library science I think it's a
wonderful set of journals but I don't
think it's representative of how open
access publishing in general would work
biomed central is much more i think the
kind of model that you'd expect I'd open
access publisher to use I know if that
answered the critique the hardwood
compact concept and question whether it
perpetuates a bucket that we no longer
need that is the journal if the journal
does not serve the purpose of
communication because people are getting
those papers us where through open
access models if it is not the primary
place where people go to use material if
it in fact it's not the tool for
long-term archiving and preservation
because others have stepped in why
should we continue to sustain a model
for the purposes of peer review and not
focus on new strategies or new
approaches to Quality Assurance in peer
review so that's and what is a
reasonable processing fee and well the
commercial publishers survive on what we
would be willing to pay um so it's a so
there's two separate questions here so
the first the first in a set of
questions I think it's completely
reasonable so you know why should we
even bother under
any kind of journals that's that's
that's basically the question this this
Harvard compact is still envisioning
that there will be well I don't know
what journals but there will be service
providers who provide a certain public
know you may be still call them
publishers I guess providing a certain
set of services no longer access
services really or at least that's not
the pride that might be some kind of
ancillary service that they'll also
provide but the primary services are
providing our this management of the
peer review process the and the
management of the production of the
final versions of articles that kind of
thing and why should we continue to
underwrite those services well those
services are different from those first
set of services you said that we don't
need anymore and there's still valuable
services and we still need to pay for
them somehow unless you think we don't
need any of that now there are people
who say we don't we okay right so but
right but in all honesty there are
people who say we don't need those
services at all we don't need peer
review for instance here's how it could
work without peer review we'll just all
put articles out in some uniform way
still sizable that's a different issue
I'll all have dl eyes so they're all
still sizable but there is no review
whatsoever and people will cite them or
not depending on whether any good or not
and we'll use instead of using the
impact factor of the journal or our
mental model of the quality of the
journal will use citation counts as a
proxy for for quality if we need some
kind of numeric notion or we'll just god
forbid actually read the articles to
decide whether they're any good so so
that's a that's a much more speculative
notion than I'm entertaining and it
might work out that way and if it does
work out that way I suppose that's fine
with me but you don't want to hang on
you all your what's the idiom of them
for hang all your something on
put all your eggs nose and not that one
is so there's some medium put your coat
on the coat hook of I don't know you
don't want to rely on that working out
that way so if it does work out that way
all the better the Harvard compact won't
cost anything because there won't be any
open access journals to fund that's fine
but if it doesn't work out that way and
it it continues to work through a
journal publishing process and Mary we
can talk about journals you know the
Harvard compact can cover journals you
know in a kind of a broad sense that is
they needn't be topic-specific in the
way we think although there's something
to be said for topic specificity in
terms of the management of the
processing the peer review process and
management of brand and premature but
maybe if it works out that it's better
to have broader journal so to speak that
don't learn topic-specific it would
still be covered under this model i
should say i'm not one of the reasons i
don't one take the next step which is to
say let's let's just rethink how
journals work entirely and maybe get rid
of them and so forth is that it's not
merely because I'm a Luddite although I
am that's not merely because of that
it's because well maybe it is just
because I'm aware no it's because I
think there's something that works about
that model and we don't know about about
alternatives and so you guy said well we
don't know about the open access public
publishing model either but that's not
entirely true we do know we do know
there are now by now thousands of open
access journals and they manage to work
even without something like the Harvard
compact even without institutions Stan
behind them and having an infrastructure
system to support them we have
infrastructure systems to support
subscription-based journals we have
library budgets willing to pay them we
have subscription agents willing to
serve as aggregators to make that whole
process efficient we have distributors
and so forth so and publishers of course
so we don't have those kinds of things
for open access journals and yet we have
a large number of Nexus journals
relatively large few thousand with a
wide range of quality from the most
prestigious to safe to say the least
prestigious so we have some experience
that it can work and we'd have more
faith in it if we knew that funding
agencies and universities were willing
to put their money where their mouth was
I have another question yeah um based on
personal experience last week many of
the scenarios that you're raising seem
to suggest authorship by say single
faculty member at Harvard I just
concluded a study with 16 co-authors and
I was looking at different open access
journals as I feel very strongly about
it but there are certain specific
journals in my field and brain imaging
that are quite prominent elsevier Wiley
has a couple journals that are very good
and I was looking at him da way
publishers and plows and whatnot and I
took a vote and it was very interesting
and lively debate amongst the 16
co-authors and I each was spitting out
statistics having to do with impact
factor and that's the main thing I want
to ask you about and I was saying some
things about eigen factor and other
people are saying this back to that
factor and the kinds of pressures from
multiple a collaboration of multiple
universities and these different types
of numbers that seemed to really at
least in my case caused a lot of
pressure me for me to steer away from
open access toward a particular
publisher so if you could comment on
this so I'm not sure that this is really
an issue about multiple authorship even
single authors are going to want to
publish in the journals
that are the most prestigious that's the
whole point of journals these days God
knows it's not about access if you want
you know putting something in a journal
is not because you want people to be
able to read it if you want people to be
able to read your article put it on your
website they can read your article it's
about getting the imprimatur of the
journal the brand name is the journals
name and so and that's true for single
author articles as well as multiple
author equus course the lid the
negotiation is more complicated if
there's multiple authors but the
underlying idea is the same and that's
why it's important to have some kind of
mechanism by which journals can change
their business model from the
subscription-based model to an open
access model because it's the journals
that have existing brand names that are
most important to become open access
journals it's fine to try to set up new
journals but they knew journal has an
inherent disadvantage over an existing
journal namely it has no brand so it's
very hard to to obtain a very high-level
brand name for a new journal it can be
done plos has done it with several
journals in my own field of artificial
intelligence what was for several years
the number one journal in artificial
intelligence was a journal called the
Journal of machine learning research
it's an open access journal and charges
no subscription fees also charges no
article processing fees it was the
number one journal by by is I impact
factor in the field and still is very
high up in fact there to open access
journals in AI both of them very high up
it out the contact I from very
prestigious journals so it could be done
but but you know things are stacked
against you I think it's going to be
easier to the easier way to get up big
brand-name open access journal is to
take a big brand-name closed access
journal and turn it open access and my
hope is that if we could extrapolate use
of something like the Harvard comp
you could actually make it possible to
allow publishers to make that move well
congratulations on on the accomplishment
of getting this resolution adopted it at
Harvard and so I'd like to hear some
trench warfare stories yeah some some
some lessons learned about what works
what doesn't work as you move this
resolution forward and then I know there
hasn't been much time since its adoption
but any episodes about what works what
doesn't work now that you're
implementing it yeah so it's a good
question what was it that made it
possible to get this policy past in fact
of Arts and Sciences in the law school I
mean there's a few things i'll mention
first is patience so it did take a solid
two years in FAS and in the law school
and you know we're now talking to other
schools at Harvard who are in some phase
of considering such a policy some are
farther along than others and it's going
to take a long time for them to I don't
know exactly how long maybe we'll be
able to this academic year some other
schools will join in maybe not I don't
know it's it's a long process and it's
important that it be a certain size it
won't be a long process or that there be
patience because you really need a very
full discussion and everyone to become
comfortable with the idea it it's it
doesn't do any good to tactically get
something passed if there isn't really
wide support for it because you can you
can pass certain policies or you can
declare certain policies it doesn't
matter if people are not actually behind
them they won't have any effect so
so it's important to be patient next
thing I say is it turned out important
to the the wording of the policy is very
important in particular this a waiver
ability was crucial I'm getting people
comfortable that there wouldn't be
unintended consequences at an individual
level because if worse comes to worst in
the face of an impending unintended
consequence one can always get a waiver
of the policy so that did a lot to
mitigate lots of different kinds of
worries third I'd say it's important
that there be it was important that
there was a perception that this was a
faculty driven process it wasn't the
library complaining about its budget it
wasn't the administration claiming that
it didn't have enough rights to your
work as you you know people are
sensitive to these kinds of things with
respect for instance to patent rights
right the university declares we own
your patents and the initial reaction
course is going to be an antagonistic
one well not so fast there you know we
should at least share and and now we're
arguing over the percentage does the
faculty member get fifty percent or
twenty-five percent or ten percent and
it becomes an adversarial situation it
you don't want it perceived that way and
it has to be perceived as the faculty
doing this on their own behalf that's
probably the most crucial aspect so
there's there's a couple of three things
that I think led to the possibility of
doing this in FAS and we're continuing
to use the same kind of method where we
introduce it to an individual faculty we
the faculty talk about it we have
meetings to talk about it we bring in
another faculty to describe the point of
it and so forth let things kind of the
discussions kind of settle throughout
the faculty before do you know take
carry on e votes or anything like that
in the crowd business model the
university through the library's by
subscriptions at a known cost a beaut
one that rises astronomically rear but
we still sort of know how much we've
budgeted for that and in the business
model you're proposing the cost of
subsidizing the author fees is not
predictable so you can't say well you
know we'll have X number of articles in
a given year how would the university
budget for this is first question just
removing that out and then long-term are
we setting up a situation in which I'll
just say the large libraries are
subsidizing the smaller libraries or the
large universities are subsidizing the
smaller universities yeah so so those
are two extremely good questions so
let's talk about you know the prediction
problem so you say well we know how much
it's going to cost from year to year for
cereals of course you don't know because
sure what I spent this year plus okay
yeah plus what that's the question so
you don't know because you renegotiate
the contracts all the time and you're
renegotiating them one by one every the
publishers do perfect price
discrimination every university sees a
different price when ago she ate each
individual University separately where
you put together consorcio and so forth
it only makes things even more
complicated to predict so you would you
have a sense and you have a sense
because you know you're doing so many
journals and so many publishers that
thing's kind of watch out and you can
say well it's probably overall it's
going to go you know ten percent more
this year than last year or whatever the
numbers and maybe so we'll have to
cancel mmm such-and-such percentage of
so the same thing extrapolating now this
Harvard compact idea the same thing
would happen you'd have a sense from
year to year how many articles we know
we know uh actually we don't one could
figure out if we
had some sensible reporting method how
many articles FAS faculty publish a year
and that number doesn't vary hugely from
year to year it does vary em there's
some statistical fluctuation but the
number of articles you know number of
articles per faculty member per year is
in you know relatively stable number if
you imagine all of them were being you
know there over time these things will
shake out that the number of articles is
stable over time that's probably true
aggregate yeah yeah and I wish I could
give you a more accurate information
about that we're just now beginning to
get information about the number of
articles published by a faculty per year
that's another story however how hard
it's been to get that information um let
me say another thing about about
managing that process I didn't talk
about caps but one of the thing that's
important to do is you don't want to by
instituting the compact so one of the
nice things about arguing for this way
look what a nice things about article
processing fees that faculty see is
suddenly the faculty are seeing an
economic signal where they never did
before part of the market failure in
subscription the subscription fee model
is that the consumer of the product was
not the purchaser of the product the
purchaser of the product was the library
and the consumer was the faculty and the
students and when you have that disjunct
between the purchaser and the consumer
consumer doesn't see the price so they
want to over-consume so you get over
consumption in elasticity of demand so
which is exactly what leads to
hyperinflation so it's certain sense
predictable that that's what you end up
with it'd be great if the faculty member
could actually see a price signal here
and article processing fees have the
potential to do that but here look I've
just said we're going to take that price
signal off of the faculty members hands
so we're undoing one of the advantages
not the only advantage but one of the
advantages of
of that system well now we're getting
into details of implementation I think
the right way to handle this is to have
a cap per faculty member in dollars
because it's dollars that we want them
to optimize on the amount of
reimbursement of these fees that they
can receive so they're they're able to
get reimbursements for articles until
they've reached their cap for the year
so each year they'd have a cap on the
amount now and of course then you can
predict exactly an upper bound on what
it's going to cost you per year my guess
is that you'd never hit that upper bound
because some facts you're going to go
under so some some might hit the capital
you set the cap relatively high so I
might hit the cap most would go under so
you'd be paying less than that so you
still if you really want a good
prediction you'd still need to do some
kind of statistical that statistical
aggregate prediction but setting a
relatively high cap at least allows a
faculty member to trade-off dollars
versus quality of the journal in exactly
the way we would like them to do there
was a second part of the question I can
remember ah yes okay so there was a
study by Cornell where they tried to
predict what would happen if every
article incurred a $1,500 article
processing fee now what would happen to
the budget for the Cornell library the
library to pay all these article
processing fees in lieu of subscription
fees and it turned out that that was
more than they were paying in
subscription fees so the first point to
make is where did this $1,500 come from
not mount come from it turns out that
the median article processing fee for
the extent open access journals is as it
turns out zero the mean is considerably
less than one thousand dollars so I
don't know where the $1,500 came came
from again this is an example
we don't extrapolate from plos biology
of 2850 that's not a representative
number but even if it were fifteen
hundred dollars remember the idea is
that universities in the India of the
compact is University as opposed to
underwrite reasonable open access
publication charges that are not
otherwise for which other funds are not
available if the research is a result of
a grant the granting agency should be
paying this and it will not be eligible
for payment from this fund and if you
look at the open access journals and
closed access journals for that matter
that charge large article processing
fees they tend to be in the life
sciences where almost all the research
is grant funded so not coincidentally by
the way and in fact their yields where
it's even the closed access journals are
people are used to paying article
processing fees of some sort or other so
so the vast bulk of a lot of those fees
would come from the grantees who are by
the way remember already paying those
fees there are a legitimate cost of just
78 in the research they should be
willing to pay the fees the particular
method we have for paid for budgeting
for those fees i think is not very good
but that's a whole other topic so so
having said all that even at Cornell
which is a very prolific institution
it's unlikely that the costs would go up
but let's imagine that they did go up
let's imagine that that at even a
reasonable per article processing fee
there was so much scholarship going on
at some University or other there might
be some universities where this is true
that the aggregate amount they're paying
for the services of the publishers for
article processing fees goes is more
than the subscription fees well so who
says that's a bad thing sounds to me
like they were getting a free ride
before they were incurring all of these
they're acquiring all these services on
the backs of all the people paying the
subscriptions why should they get that
free ride I mean if you're a
a believer in markets and i am i'm a
believer in working markets not so happy
about the non-working markets that we're
so familiar with these days and one of
them is this subscription based market
but if we have a working market in
article processing fees then let the
chips fall where they may with regard to
who's paying what because they're
getting the services than they should be
paying for the services it kind of joked
about this earlier but are other
universities following in the footsteps
and I don't know if you can answer this
or someone else here where does Columbia
stand in this whole issue I'll defer to
people at Columbia to talk about
Columbia stands there are other
universities that have various sorts of
open access policies of one sort or
another ranging from exhortation that
faculty ought to make their articles as
broadly available as possible to more
specific kinds of things to mandates
that faculty are required to deposit
their articles in an open access
repository all kinds of different
approaches and that's a good thing to
try different different possibilities
the only instance I know of someone
following essentially of an institution
following essentially this particular
Harvard model is the Stanford School of
Education which voted sometime this
summer I think essentially word-for-word
identical policy for the education
school and I understand that now that
may be under consideration by the Arts
and Sciences school at Stanford as well
just following up on the question about
where Columbia is I'd say that we're
probably where Stewart described Harvard
being a couple of years before the
resolution was passed I think our
scholarly communication program now is
with this series of lectures and and
other visits to academic departments
starting to raise the conversation at
Columbia the University Senate did pass
a resolution about two years ago in
support of open access is a very general
statement but nothing like the Harvard
resolution in terms of impact on faculty
I wanted to pick up on your comment that
it's too soon yet to know what the
compliance is going to be like and just
ask what sorts of teeth you're able to
put in the resolution to you know to
make it happen and do you think there'll
be a sort of community social pressure
unfelt e to deposit and to comply you
can imagine various kinds of carrots and
sticks and and I've imagined them all
but it as it turns out you can't really
deploy the sticks you know when push
comes to shove this is why the notion of
a mandate is not the right way to think
about this kind of policy there is no
such thing as a mandate if you can't
force faculty to do anything I mean I
assume this is true here too it
certainly is true at Harvard there's no
there's no threat that you can make with
any teeth so you're talking to there's
no teeth in the end what you need is to
have people think it's a good idea and
in their interest to do so and to make
it as easy as possible for them to
comply so we're going through a set of
things to sort of presses do that in a
lot of outreach and a lot of support for
faculty and we don't know what's going
to work we're trying a bunch of
different things we're just getting
underway the office
so new that there's been no office to
even do this kind of stuff so really has
just begun this process of trying to get
faculty aware of what they need to do
helping them do it and so forth is just
getting underway so when I say I can't
predict I really really can't predict
what's going to work but I hope in the
fullness of time say by the end of this
academic year to have a much better idea
where we are what's working what's not
working and so forth it's not there's
not a magic bullet here I mean you you
can't just pass the policy and say now
we're done I mean that's that's kind of
the beginning of the process not the not
the end of it
I've I this may just be me but I've
heard I know I've actually heard people
say that under the I can't remember the
name of the term but that the model
where the author of the scholar pays for
the services they're getting yes I've
heard that advocated I think you're
advocating something else that would
what you know take care of that problem
that the university pay for all the
services that publishers provide but I
personally can't see how anybody would
or how the former model could work
because of the differential and ability
to pay of skywards I mean when I was a
graduate student I managed to get
something published but I would have had
to think very carefully about it if I'd
had to pay really anything for it and it
may be tiered can you address that
question that's right I I think you're
absolutely right and so hey asking a
faculty member to pay an article
processing fee now we've already decided
that the services the publishers provide
are important to the university and the
university should pay them now we
decided that under a model where we hid
those charges in subscription fees but
nothing's changed we still think it's
important to the University to pay them
and that's why I say the university
should put up or shot I mean the
university should pay and and there's
there is no reason that just because a
biologist happens to have a grant to pay
those fees they should be able to
publish whereas a person the classics
department who doesn't have a grant
doesn't get to publish wait that's just
not how it works right and this that's
not how we've structured the Academy and
I the fact that the the revenue
structure of a publisher has changed
shouldn't affect the university's
thinking about what research is valuable
to disseminate and isn't means that
they're just separate questions so I
think you're absolutely right but
if you imagined talked about a dystopian
scenario let's talk about utopian
scenario let's let's imagine that we
extrapolate all of this stuff to the
point where now open access journals
become the the norm the bulk of journals
are open access journals instead of the
bulk being closed access terrace they're
never all going to be open access
journals that's a whole other
conversation why that's so but with the
bulk of them become open access journals
and all the infrastructure that we've
devoted to the closed access
subscription based system we've now got
set up for the open access journals we
have funding funding model for them and
all of the infrastructure for work for
dealing with that funding and working
with the funding agencies and so forth
in that scenario articles are available
open access through the publishers and
they're being paid for services
including make making them and keeping
the available archive room so forth
what's the role of a repository then
well arguably not much so to a certain
extent this repository idea is is a
temporary fix until such time if it ever
occurs and I'm not too sanguine that
really we move to wholesale to this
other model because there is something a
little odd about University the
individual universities or maybe groups
of universities running these these
repositories now to the extent that
there are in that temporary period which
may extend forever today to the extent
that during the temporary period there
are economies of scale in running
repositories you'd expect to see
university is getting together to to run
them jointly and that kind of thing
that's that's all fine
you look we're going through the same
point in different nuances so
essentially the imperfect model we have
now is that the the services that
publishers provide covering of wide
range are paid indirectly by the
consumers of the product not directly by
the consumers other partners you pointed
out but the libraries that consume the
research are the ones that are paying it
they happen to coincide a lot with the
producers of the product the same
institutions are producing and consuming
but the the cost model that the Harvard
compact is trying is you know moving
towards shifts that to the the producers
now the arc will be the value accrues
both ways there's value to the people
producing researchers value to the
people consuming research for the
institutions doing the same it's not a
closed system there are there's research
happening outside of academic context
and so forth do you see any prospect of
a mixed model where the cost and value
are more are distributed across that
chain of production consumption more
evenly so if you're a little careful
here there's the producers and consumers
of the research and there's the
producers and consumers of the
publishers product and those are two
different things so you're right we've
moved from the produce from the
consumers of the research we haven't
moved we're entertaining moving from the
consumers of the research to the
producers of the research well with
respect to the product that the
publisher is selling now the question is
what is that product at the moment that
product is a combination of two things
it's some services that the publisher
provides to the author in terms of
providing reviews and working with the
author to implement those reviews and
copy editing and typesetting of the of
the article production of the actual
page makeup of the article and so forth
that's first copy cost thats related to
a service directly for the author
they're also providing access through
either shipping printed copies around or
controlling access to a website or
something it turns out that the
relative costs to the publisher of those
two things is very different so
increasingly the cost for the latter is
getting smaller relative to the cost of
the former so it makes sense that the
revenue model should should switch that
way too so I don't think it's the case
that we're moving from the consumers of
the product to the producers of a lot of
the product we're moving from the so the
libraries are not the consumers of the
product just a little bit of the product
that access part we're moving to the
actual consumers of the product who are
the authors who are receiving the
benefits of the peer review vetting
filtering production and imprimatur
they're the ones that are receiving
those benefits so we're just moving to a
model that matches those up better now
the question is well maybe we should mix
it a little bit okay maybe the bulk of
it should be an article processing fee
but a little bit of it should be a
distribution fee our subscription fee
the problem is that there's a big
difference between charging zero for a
subscription fee and charging ten cents
for a subscription fee but just the
smallest increment puts you in a
completely different situation and now
I'll make one I'll make one kind of
Philip on that which is given that the
marginal cost of online distribution is
essentially zero I really don't see
charging for that there are print copies
however and print copies have other
advantages other than access in fact in
a situation where there is free online
access the the purpose of a print copy
you no longer is access but it still has
a purpose and that purpose is archival
and it makes perfect sense to charge for
that so even open access journals ought
to be charging for their print copies
and libraries ought to be buying the
print copies
because that that completes the chain of
that part of the value is fixity and
archival strikes and that has other
potential and things like Porter going
on the value proposition that's right so
important cause an interesting example
so there there's a very specific service
they're selling and it's a valuable
service and service are providing it's a
valuable service and people should be
willing to pay for that service but it
but the right way to think about it is
exactly this way what are the services
that are going to provide and let's pay
for those services rather than wrapping
it all up and hiding it inside of a
subscription fee for the article for The
Journal as a whole or worse a
subscription fee for all of the journals
from a publisher as a whole with the
Harvard compact work for schools that
aren't our one so that aren't research
is school so not Harvard's not
Columbia's not ones with large research
budgets what about smaller school it
works even better for those schools so
to the extent that a school doesn't
generate many publications by their
authors the Harvard compact is extremely
inexpensive so down to the point where
if you have universities that don't you
turn any research it's free to sign on
to the Harvard compact why not and yet
you still get as you get more and more
universities signing on you increase the
decrease the risk to a publisher to
change business model